the SCP foundation's existence might be
a frightening thing to some but if you
ask us it's comforting of course the
existence of the foundation implies the
existence of all the mind-meltingly
terrifying entities they Combat on a
daily basis but doesn't it put your mind
at least a little at ease to know
somebody out there knows what's going on
after all sometimes knowledge is the
only light we have in the darkness it is
Humanity's greatest strength to know
things and to act accordingly from
knowledge we can understand our enemies
and the threats they pose against us
from knowledge we can build sturdier
defenses from knowledge we can develop
the means to finally effectively strike
back and nobody among the ranks of
humanity has more knowledge than the SCP
Foundation so what happens when the
knowledge of the SCP Foundation fails us
what happens when a concept eludes even
them a concept up like say
scp-2317 an old wooden door that hides
within a truly terrible secret a secret
known by many as the Devourer of Worlds
a beast every bit as powerful and
unpleasant as that name suggests the SCP
Foundation performs a complex set of
rituals every single day to keep him
contained and if the top brass of the
foundation is to be believed then these
rituals are effective but I think we all
know better than to believe everything
we're told around here don't we the
truth is beyond the wooden door known as
scp-2317 there is a hellish desert World
underneath which the Devourer of Worlds
awaits he is kept in place Bound by
ancient chains created by a race that
has long since been lost to the history
books and while the foundation tells its
underlings that the rituals d-class
Personnel perform here every day helps
to keep these chains in place this is
little more than a placebo the rituals
only exist to make the foundation feel
like they're doing something to buy time
while they figure out an actual lasting
solution in reality based on the
foundation's current knowledge These
Chains could break any day now and sadly
there's nothing they can do about it
this may seem like the worst possible
truth to learn but we can think of one
even worse truth that any day now is
today when the chain breaks the ground
begins to rumble worldwide Like An
Earthquake so great it might even split
the planet in two no conventional
scientists anywhere in the world has any
idea what's happening but the SCP
Foundation does for the first time in
recorded history the entire o5 Council
are quaking it's Judgment Day and their
every sin is on an Express trip back to
get them they put out a call to dispatch
every single mobile task force worldwide
to come to site 19 and combat this new
threat but deep down the council member
silently worried that this would be
about as effective as the Sham rituals
they claimed every day would protect
them meanwhile site 19 exploded most of
the foundation personnel and anomalies
stationed there perished in an instant
as a giant clawed hand rose out of the
ground grasping at the sunlight for the
first time in millions of years since
imprisonment its sheer size hundreds of
kilometers in height displaces and
destroys the land around it as it climbs
free from the earth the Devourer of
Worlds is a monster of such magnitude
that a dwarfs even the foundation's
mightiest weapons but their mobile task
Forces fight valiantly or perhaps
foolishly nonetheless the foundation
went in with its finest resources and
weaponry from Advanced cruise missiles
to classified laser projectile weapons
that conventional militaries wouldn't be
finding for another century and all that
amounted to be the strength of getting a
mid-rate birthday Clown's cheap cream
pie to the face the thick scaly hide of
the Beast somehow rejected everything
they threw at it Jets were scrambled
flying around the devours gargantuan
head and peppering its great eye with
bullets followed by heat guided Rockets
nothing the monster simply swatted them
out of the air with its claws down below
ground forces mobilized on Mass from
tanks to turrets unleashing all kinds of
Hell onto the Devourer of Worlds from
below and still what good did it do the
monster simply kept walking killing
thousands with every footfall its
magnitude was simply unfathomable
Scranton reality anchors were placed at
its feet in hopes of creating some kind
of trap but its ancient feet defied
their Force every mobile task force from
hammer down to samsara did what they
could and what they could do ultimately
amounted to a fat lot of nothing the
Rampage of the Devourer was undeterred
third within an hour he would reach a
population Center and then true hell
would be Unleashed upon the human race
but sometimes the only thing that could
destroy something inhuman was something
so much more than human over in the low
risk humanoid containment center of
Psych 17
scp-343 perhaps better known as God was
watching all the horror unfold in his
Mind's Eye so the Devourer was finally
free and wreaking havoc on the world
that he put so much effort into creating
no no that simply would not do how could
he let such a vulgar creature taking
billions of years of beauty love
kindness happiness and natural majesty
and turn it all into Ash and dust he
would not stand for it but God while
unimaginably powerful is a philosopher
not a warrior it would be not only
beneath his Celestial position but
dangerous for all life on Earth if he
were to Unleash the Power required to
this destroyed the Devourer himself the
armies of God are the greatest in heaven
or Earth but he would need a champion to
lead them and while the operatives of
the SCP Foundation fought and died
bravely for the human race
scp-343 blipped out of site 17 and
reappeared in the Middle East where his
Champion would be waiting guarding the
gate to Paradise
scp-001 in this case known as the gate
Guardian a huge glowing humanoid with
wings made of fire and a sword hotter
than the sun capable of cleaving its
enemies apart on the atomic level
typically any being who traveled within
a kilometer of the gate Guardian would
receive this treatment a strike so
powerful that in the aftermath not even
dust would remain but when scp-343
appeared mere feet away from the mighty
gate Guardian the guardian fell to one
knee and bowed its glowing head in holy
reverence Master the guardian said you
have returned to me long last I will do
thy bidding what must be done
Ariel God sent greatly an enemy is at
the gates one more powerful than this
world has ever known battle him while I
gather the armies do whatever it takes
he must be stopped the gate Guardian
Uriel Rose to his feet spreading his
great Wings of Fire it shall be done my
Lord Uriel boomed and faster than any
human being could possibly perceive it
he had taken off into the sky leaving
the gate behind him unguarded for the
first time in the memory of the human
race God's side it was time to finally
open it back with the Devourer and the
mobile Task Force Army trying in vain to
slow his advance for the most part the
creature's hide was so thick it was hard
to even know if he noticed most of the
puny humans firing on it some of the
ones down below driven half mad with
fear rage and the crushing weight of
futility pulled out knives swords and
bayonets and ran at the creature's feet
stabbing away even as their blades were
blunted and destroyed of course the
Devourer of Worlds paid no mind to them
it adds something else and its sights a
human City a mere handful of steps away
yes yes so teeming with life such
delicious morsels the Devourer would
live up to his terrifying namesake and
feast on them all yes yes
it would be delicious as he crushed
further thousands of mobile task force
soldiers below him just by walking he
could hardly wait down below things had
never seemed so hopeless was this how it
ended one impotent Last Stand as a
hungry monster of inconceivable size
bulldozed through life and civilization
and left nothing nobody in its wake was
this howl the complicated but proud
story of the human race would come to an
end down here in the worthless
blood-soaked mud that's when something
changed the sky once blotted out with
the devourer's shadow was lit up by a
brilliant white light a light so
dazzling so holy and pure that he gave
even the Devourer pause the human beings
down below wept with joy and numinous
awe it was him it was
scp-001 the gate Guardian spreading his
fiery wings and drawing his solar sword
my master ordered me to destroy you
his deafening psychic voice boomed
unless you shall be destroyed prepare to
meet your maker
the Devourer immediately let out a world
shaking Roar so powerful that many of
the humans down below felt their brains
rattling and their ears literally
beginning to bleed the beasts reached
for yurio with its huge clawed hand
moving at impossible speeds for a
creature its size onlookers gasped in
shock luckily for a surprisingly fast as
the Devourer of Worlds was Uriel was
faster like a flash of an exploding
light bulb the guardian darted out of
the devourer's palm and cleaved a
glowing gash into the monster's wrist
with his solar sword the creature
growled taken off guard it was the first
time in millions of years since it was
attacked and bound by those impossible
Celestial armies that it had felt pain
what was this mysterious Warrior of fire
all the Devourer knew was that if it
wanted to turn the planet Earth into an
all-you-can-eat buffet it would need to
do away with this glowing nuisance first
the psychic voice of the gate Guardian
commanded as it flew in for another
strike this time cleaving into the
beast's torso and leaving a long glowing
scar but he didn't stop there the gate
Guardian had changed posture from a
defensive territorial stance to an
all-out offensive Warpath as commanded
by his all-powerful master yoriel was
not arrogant he could see that the Beast
he was battling was undeniably
formidable but he had slain formidable
enemies before and he would do so again
now taking advantage of the comparative
slowness and clunkiness of the Devourer
a natural side effect of its truly
immense size Uriel decided to stay
mobile flying around the Devourer like
an electron orbiting the nucleus of an
atom at any moment that he with his
Warriors judgment detected an opening a
weakness he flew in and struck with
extreme Fury leaving another glowing
scar in the monster's thick scales that
fizzled with the impossible heat of his
sword each time time the Beast gave a
grunt tour growl and Confused pain as it
desperately flailed to try and grab the
holy Warrior meanwhile the SCP
Foundation had figured out what was
happening and was reorienting its focus
while the gate Guardian fought against
and distracted the Devourer of Worlds
all surviving Foundation Personnel under
the instruction of the o5 council
converged on the nearest city to the
Devourer they would evacuate as many as
they could buying them more time to
calculate some kind of meaningful
counter-offensive to this XK Class end
of the world scenario if this really
could be Humanity's Last Stand they
would go out swinging and leave their
opponent with a black eye while the
evacuation efforts were underway Uriel
continued his Relentless assault against
the Devourer carving scar after scar
into the monster's body he could not
tell if he was leaving much lasting
damage but at the very least he was
getting the abomination's attention
after striking its body countless times
though yorio finally felt enough to go
against the creature's obvious weak
point its huge staring cycloptic eye
perhaps with a decisive strike he could
blind the Beast faster than the speed of
sound yoriel orbited the beast's body
and reoriented himself in front of its
eye he could feel the nanoseconds
passing as he charged raising a sword
now would be the time to end this but
wait what's that why is the devourer's
eyes suddenly glowing red before even
Uriel had time to react a tremendous
force of pure energy blasted forth from
the devourer's eye bombarding the
Angelic Soldier and firing him straight
into the ground below he did not even
know the monster possessed such a power
and now the force of it was hammering
him into the Earth the blast kept going
for a few more seconds zapping uriel's
strength and introducing him to a long
forgotten pain when the beam was done
firing Uriel felt as though he could
barely move he was a Sitting Duck that's
when the Devourer began marching towards
him every step rattling the Earth even
as the threat loomed Uriel couldn't move
was this the end forgive me master
you're real sad I have failed you then
Uriel noticed something several
projectiles firing towards the
devourer's head seemingly out of thin
air a volley of intercontinental
ballistic missiles each equipped with a
nuclear payload exploded against the
creature's head blasting it with a shock
wave that rattled the mighty creature on
its feet had human beings made such
weapons if they could still fight even
after all this yuria thought then I must
fight too I must fight to my last breath
as the Devourer studied itself
recovering from the nuclear bombardment
to the Head Uriel rose with a terrifying
Warriors Roar feeling his holy power
returned to him his sword ignited and he
charged forward faster than ever before
ready to strike clear and true Into The
devourer's Wretched heart before the
Beast could react Uriel shoved his sword
into the center of its chest causing
veins of agonizing flame to spread out
over its whole body at long last he had
well and truly harmed the unharmable
that knowledge Sanctified him even as
the Devourer of Worlds grabbed Uriel in
his fist and squeezed the life out of
the warrior for God for the last time
good the Devourer thought in its own way
I can finally carry on now you fought
bravely
set a booming voice from above the Beast
your sacrifice will not be in vain that
much I promise you
confuse the Devourer turned and looked
Skyward only to see a sight that struck
purer and undiluted awe into even him it
was God and his army
scp-343 floated in the sky lightning
emanating from his very being around him
glowing Angelic Warriors each as large
and as powerful as yoriel and as
numerous as the stars in the sky above
God pointed at the Devourer now my
children he said take that thing apart
for me wants an anomaly of your own
check out scpswag.com for high quality
SCP merch now go check out
scp-2317 the Devourer of Worlds a door
to another world an scp-001 the gate
Guardian for more on today's Cosmic
combatants